You have to help me find out
what happened to my husband.
Seeking answers is never
a straight line.
♪♪
Oh, my God.
Police are closing the case.
POPPY:
His widow deserves answers.
You saw the same thing I did.
You just don't wanna face it.
Micah, I'm gonna do the podcast,
force the police to look
deeper into the case.
I won't only find out
what you want me to know.
-Air it all.
-POPPY: This season...
we will present the information
ignored by the media
and the police.
We know what our friends
want us know about
their marriages.
POPPY:
Is Micah lying to me?
♪ I see the darkness ♪
I'm worried about Poppy,
her marriage.
♪ Leading me ♪
She's coming loose at the seams.
Do you trust her?
If you don't work with Poppy,
she'll work against you.
POPPY: She lied,
tried to gaslight me.
How's that make you feel?
Like burning it down.
You thought
that you could control me.
I don't know
what you're talking about.
POPPY:
You have to be honest with me.
Why did you even want me
involved with this case?
♪ And no answer to ♪
My name is Poppy Parnell,
and I will not give up
until I have...
the truth.
♪ I know your secrets ♪
♪ I know your lies ♪